[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en el estudio Marta bienvenida
buena mañana de jueves y vamos a iniciar
esta revista de prensa viendo como toda
la prensa internacional Está tratando
estos últimos días las protestas que se
realizan en Irán surgidas a raíz de la
muerte de la joven bajo custodia
policial más a mini presuntamente por
llevar mal el velo puesto el empezamos
con el middle isaí también recordemos
Marta para hacer un inciso ayer en su
discurso ante la ONU el presidente de
este país se abrahim Racing no mencionó
absolutamente nada lo que estaba
ocurriendo en su país antes pues habló
de los Derechos Humanos el respeto de
las mujeres pero no mencionó nada lo que
ocurre internamente Así es Buenos días
Raúl el midelis hay Abre este informe
titulando las furiosas protestas en Irán
atraen la simpatía de todos los rincones
de la sociedad hablando un poco Pues de
que estas protestas no Solo han atraído
a las capas más que normalmente son las
que lideran este tipo de manifestaciones
anti gubernamentales sino que se han
hecho de manera transversal dice pues
como comentábamos en los noticieros que
más
mini Perdón murió bajo custodia policial
y pues por presuntamente llevar el
puesto sostiene este análisis que la
policía de la moral que es quien
presuntamente asesinó a esta joven de 22
años suele estar a las afueras del metro
de Teherán Pues fiscalizando un poco
como las mujeres llevan puesto este velo
sostiene además que las mujeres están
bueno adscritas y sujetas a estas
estrictas a estos estrictos Perdón
códigos de vestimenta desde la
revolución iraní de 1979 pero que como
comentabas tu Raúl desde la llegada al
poder de ebrahim Rising pues la
fiscalización ha aumentado además cita a
analistas que dicen que a diferencia con
otras protestas anteriores hoy la gente
canta consignas arriesga su vida por una
demanda cultural que es el fin del
hitjab obligatorio y la opresión de las
mujeres iraníes claro también de sentir
mucha presión Pues en las personas en
las calles sobre todo las mujeres con
una policía que esté viendo cómo se
visten no vamos a ver cómo lo resalta
lemont en esta misma línea titula
manifestaciones en Irán revelan una vez
más un régimen apartado de su pueblo
sostienen que estas protestas denotan
que los iraníes están sujetos a una
posición política pues que no apoyan y
dicen Pues que el régimen ha respondido
como habitualmente hace que es con la
Fuerza bruta pues hablábamos no de más
de 17 muertos en estas últimas en estas
últimas protestas dicen las últimas
manifestaciones revelan una vez más que
el régimen está alejado de su pueblo y
centrado por completo en su
supervivencia sostienen además que
Rising pues se ha alejado de pues su
antecesor hazard rugeini
el lideraba está relativa indulgencia
para con las mujeres y vimos pues este
también distanciamiento de esta
desconexión con su discurso en la ONU
como que en su país no estuviera pasando
absolutamente nada cambiamos ahora de
tema porque en una investigación del
mediodía usted ha descubierto una
supuesta trama de corrupción por parte
de las autoridades de Florida con estos
envíos de los migrantes a Estados
demócratas no Marta una polémica también
por jugar digamos de alguna manera con
estos migrantes con las necesidades de
ellos para usarlos como armas políticas
también de Cara a las elecciones a medio
término de noviembre tal cual Raúl es
una investigación de keplestein y dice
ron de Sant is fletó aviones de un
donante Aliado del partido republicano
para llevar a los migrantes a marta's
que es esta Isla donde suelen pues
dirigirse en verano las altas élites de
los demócratas no esto es una trama un
poco complicada Y es que el estado de
Florida Pues destino 12 millones de
dólares pues provenientes del fondo para
hacer frente a la pandemia destino 12
millones de dólares para pues hacer
frente a este programa de emigrantes no
de devolución de migrantes a Estados
demócratas sostiene Pues que uno de
estas empresas que tiene Pues vínculos
con el partido demócrata fue quien se
llevó la concesión de 600.000 de 615 mil
dólares Perdón para pues trasladar a 48
migrantes venezolanos a esta Isla esto
Pues supuestamente fue un win win para
ron de sandis para el gobernante de
Florida Pues que él mandó a los
migrantes y además Pues el jefe que
había asignado esa cantidad económica
para llevar a estos migrantes Pues fue
también beneficiado con una concesión de
esta empresa que se llama vetrol systems
además dice que no es la única vez que
ha hecho betro systems estas donaciones
porque ya ha participado en otros
procesos de donaciones también para el
traslado de migrantes cita una Bueno
pues una cita de ron de Sand vamos a
gastar cada centavo asegurándonos de
sacarlos de ese estado desantes también
que correría por la presidencia y los
2024 y se dice que esto también es un
juego de poder para ver quién es el más
fuerte digamos con su principal rival
que sería el presidente Donald Trump
todo está por verse destacamos también
la editorial del medio colombiano el
tiempo que habla precisamente de los
migrantes Marta Sí dice del sueño a La
pesadilla es este sueño Tan idealizado
americano Pues que para muchos migrantes
se ha convertido en eso en una pesadilla
cifra este editorial del tiempo de
Colombia que la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza pues cifra en 2,5
millones de migrantes detenidos desde el
31 de agosto de 2021 hasta el 1 de
octubre o sea Perdón desde el 1 de
octubre de 2021 hasta el 31 de agosto de
2022 y que de ellos 1,3 millones han
sido expulsados cita este editorial del
tiempo que este es un terrible drama que
podría asimilarse a una versión
contemporánea del mito del sismo porque
así como el personaje luego está
condenado a subir una pesada roca y
cuando está a punto de conquistar la
cima esta se vuelve a despeñar los
inmigrantes recién expulsados lo
intentan una y otra vez exponiendo sus
vidas y las de sus familias a la más
siniestra muerte y son expulsados Marta
Gracias por toda la información de la
revista de prensa de hoy jueves mañana
con más revista de prensa Gracias Marta
Gracias Raúl mañana más